[Music]
money heist's final season went out with
a bang
okay well actually quite a few bangs
filming in real helicopters sending gold
grits through pipes body cams and a
complex scene that could only be
performed once before a full set was
destroyed yeah typical money heist stuff
and we've got all the footage of what it
was really like to shoot on this set
no norwegian oil rig no problem there's
a tropical fix for that who doesn't love
a good tropical location chute
the rig in the canary islands was
actually under repair when it made its
tv debut and thanks to cgi it was the
perfect replacement the crew was totally
digging working in the sunshine but the
actors keeping oh too cozy in their
hardcore cold weather wear
well we wouldn't blame them if they
would have preferred actually filming in
frigid norway
hiding pedro alonso's illness might have
been the only good part of this
situation for the actor passengers we
will be reaching a height of zero inches
on our journey today come fly with the
money heist crew or at least pretend to
while the helicopter is safely on the
ground ding dong okay brilliant it is
pretty cool to see the actors in an
actual helicopter instead of just a
partial form we can only imagine how fun
it was to be behind possibly the safest
helicopter steering wheel there ever was
i ain't saying they're gold diggers okay
well actually in this case that's
exactly what they're doing and honestly
is there anything more satisfying than
watching them expertly pull off this
heist
send those gold grits into the pipes
team
hello
is that spider-man
nah just a bunch of people on a mission
to shut down the heist
looking incredibly cool while doing so
if we're being honest even without
editing the team as per usual impresses
holding back clearly wasn't an issue for
the money heist crew
anyone need rain boots
or an umbrella for that matter
we totally dig the room turned pool vibe
even though it's kind of weird to see
all these cameras covered in plastic
and then they also made the impossible
possible for the sake of this key
activity totally not practical but has
the money heist crew ever taken the easy
route if it works it works
fingers crossed they don't mess this up
a daring move for sure but not a shock
with this team the prep required immense
this is crazy every single aspect they'd
created would inevitably be crushed as
soon as action was called the explosions
and roof falling in are beyond
impressive but that jerk vest pull so
perfectly timed in the midst of all that
chaos the cherry on top
no turning back now
all right it's go time
unlike anything we'd ever seen before
this major battle didn't disappoint
thank goodness they nailed it since they
spent nearly a month shooting scene 22
alone
no matter what was needed they brought
it weapons dust and live explosions were
center stage the actors worked hard
enough on set so the editing team took
over and managed to make them look even
better it's a group effort and if we
know anything it's that this team slays
is it hot in here
light that scene ablaze
while it looks full of action and fun
for the performers filming these feisty
sequences was actually some of the most
boring time on set because so much of
the time they were just waiting
resetting and repeating all over again
sorry is that a baby
it's messy dark cold and pretty much the
last place a person would ever want to
give birth but after all isn't this the
kind of scene money heist does best
[Music]
just in case you needed confirmation not
to try this at home najwa nimri had her
work cut out for her all power to you
you absolute boss woman as for that baby
well no real babies appeared on the set
but this silicone baby covered in cream
did the trick even though it kind of
creeped out the actors on set it's bad
it's
real bad a baby that is so real looking
combined with weird sounds
yeah not such a cute look ouch yep
that's real blood
ouch the sharp blade going at jose
manuel poga was all too real meaning it
drew real blood on the first tape
luckily the actor looks on the bright
side and considered it an important mark
a bit of bogota that would always be
with him
a bit intense but sure whatever floats
your boat luckily there were medics
there who could actually give him
stitches live on set
yes you heard us correctly
5 star rating for medical care
say it ain't so
saying goodbye to tokyo might just be
one of the most painful losses on money
heist emotions and tension level on the
set
we're guessing somewhere around an 11
out of 10. i don't want to go i don't
want to go it was definitely an epic
scene for the actress to rap on going
out with a literal bang
[Music]
okay does anyone know where the pacharan
is
it's party time
real candles real fish and very real
alcohol the perfect combo to bring the
hake scene to the screen
the professor really does know the best
way to let loose
we're glad the whole cast really
indulged and went all out real shots and
all
you want to put the camera where as if
acting out being on a total trip weren't
tricky enough try maneuvering with giant
body cams rigged up i am so confused
right now they filmed every which way
for this entire sequence and the final
effect
totally worth it acebo was all in from
the very beginning
and that she did
can anyone give me a hand
how many ways can the professor be tied
up was the name of the game and the show
gave us plenty of options to work with
oh this is uncomfortable
though alvaro morte might not have been
a fan of the deal as always he was a
good sport plus he got to unexpectedly
let loose in that hake scene so we'd say
the production and morte were even
do we have to film this again
the final volume of part 5 of money
heist was anything but easy for the
professor he found himself in tricky
situations often quite literally tied up
in this case
no matter how you spin it a scene like
this is never fun to film but since they
had to make sure all those camera angles
were captured the actor was stuck doing
take after take good thing it was all
worth it in the end
if they can dream it they can do it the
combination of acting skills
unbelievable practical effects and cgi
to tie everything together was a solid
10 out of 10 for the final part of money
heist